he looked me straight in the eye and
said harry you should understand that
common sense is not an appropriate tool
for a police officer
this is what happens when you stand in
defense of a member of the public whose
only alleged crime is posting
a flag on facebook
there was no rationale no reason no
argument no appeal to basic humanity no
appeal to history no appeal to context
no appeal to anything that was going to
stop them on their mission to make an
arrest over me
okay
as far as they're concerned it doesn't
matter if they're on the wrong side of
the law providing in their minds they're
on the right side of history that's the
problem that we have
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
today is a notorious thought criminal
harry miller welcome back to
trigonometry thanks for having me on
it's been fantastic it was great i
enjoyed it last time you will note that
i'm not wearing the uh the jumper that
you so roundly mocked in um uh after i
was on last time it was uh
yeah it was nice it was a nice blue
piece i think with like a a maroon sort
of cross line i remember watching a show
a few weeks ago you did mention me and
you um
thank you for not reporting us to the
police uh but harry we're joking around
of course and it's great to see you
again i hope you're well um we were
actually not gonna do any interviews in
august at all uh because we've just come
back from a really long trip we're quite
tired we need a bit of rest and
recuperation but while we were in
america
we saw
this thing going on with you
and i just can't tell you how
unbelievably angry it made me seeing it
particularly because we were in the u.s
we were enjoying the freedoms of the
country people being able to say what
they think and blah blah blah blah blah
and then we see on social media that you
are involved in incent we'll get you to
talk about it but essentially where a
man is being arrested for sharing a meme
on facebook right so just take us
through it from the beginning
what's happened
okay well sometime earlier this year uh
lawrence fox um put as his profile
picture uh this image of four
intersectional trans flags um which were
set so that the the vector in them the
the i think it's the um the black lives
matter vector uh the the race theory
vector
if you position them in certain way it
gives the impression perhaps of a
swastika
now lawrence fox didn't invent this meme
i i've seen this meme for the last two
or three years so he's a joke thief yeah
yeah exactly
it's been around for a long long time
but nevertheless laurence has got i know
quarter of a million followers so when
he uh tweeted this out um it got some
traction
an army veteran from aldershot 30-year
service three tours of duty a chest
filled with medals including for
loyal service good conduct etc
uh i believe that he was a warrant
officer he was a he's a proper sound guy
royal green jacket
on a facebook forum a discussion forum
forum called wait for it mass debaters
i know what they're doing there yeah
exactly so he um he put a picture of the
of the the flag and all he put
underneath it was what do we think to
that
so it was prompting it was prompting
discussion that was all
so one sunday morning about three weeks
ago um three police officers three
police officers turned up at this house
uh he immediately said is this a crime
or is this a non-crime and they said
it's a crime
i said
said what crime they said section one
two seven communications act so
sat them down and this this section for
people who are not aware is about being
grossly offensive
what section one two seven of the
communications acts is when you when you
send by electronic means
um
an image or message which is grossly
offensive obscene or of a highly
menacing nature okay so there is an
objective standard attached to it it's
not based on a subjective feeling it's
what would the person on the clapham
omnibus think about this would they
think that this is grossly offensive if
the answer is yes then you know it means
that it meets the bar if the answer is
it's offensive but you know say what
then it doesn't meet the bar
[Music]
so
they sat him down and they said right
okay um these are your options
they pull out a bit of paper and they
said you can either sign here this is a
this is our community resolution
agreement
uh signed between you and the victim and
he said well who is the victim they said
we don't have to tell you that
um okay yeah they said it would be
against that policy to tell you who the
victim is but nevertheless you have to
sign this and part of that is that you
admit your guilt you are guilty of a
breach of section 127
we will hold it on your record and then
we will downgrade your crime to a
non-crime so that's a good thing because
that means that um you know you're not a
criminal uh but you will be able to
release this information about your
hateful nature uh to any potential
employer on an enhanced dbs check for
the next six years but in order to help
mitigate that one of the things that you
will sign up to do is to go on a on a on
a course and
yeah we heard this before yeah
and they they they they said he
he said what's the course called well he
well he said to them um is this a course
to check my thinking because he was
obviously channeling a little bit of me
there
and they said oh no this is a
re-education course to teach you how not
to get arrested in the future
we have a re-education course for people
who share memes on facebook yeah yeah
yeah and one of the things that they
told him that he would learn one of the
one of the life skills that these um
these young officers
who had a combined age of about 25
uh said this sort of 56 54 year old army
veteran they said well for instance in
the future before you post
on social media you will learn the skill
of going to your neighbor and asking
them for approval
and if they say it's okay then the
chances are it will be okay and he said
i'm a 54 year old man i'm not asking my
neighbors before i go on [ __ ]
facebook
and they said well their point will mate
they said well the option well the
alternative then is that we will
prosecute you
and he said well
before we go on he said
one i didn't i'm not the originator of
this mean it's a fella called lawrence
fox and they said that doesn't count
you're the one who posted it and
somebody has been caused anxiety based
on your post
i said right okay well there's also this
other bloke called harry miller
um and the high court has the high court
in the court of appeal have recently
said that uh you know this sort of non
recording of non-crime hate incidents is
illegal it's unlawful and they said well
have the high court as the court of
appeal written to you he said well no of
course i said well in that case it
doesn't count
he said
well that's ridiculous the court doesn't
need to write to me personally for for
for the ruling to apply they said no
we're not talking about it you've got a
decision to make are you going to sign
your guilt away or are we going to
prosecute well let me have a think about
it so they agreed to come back in 10
days time 6 o'clock on a thursday night
that's when he got hold of he got hold
of us so we watched the video because
his house
is there's videos everywhere it's like
he's expecting an attack from isis at
any moment
everywhere there's video
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
so we watched the video and i was i was
absolutely stunned we had to peel my
barrister off the floor on several
occasions because she kept passing out
with the degree of awfulness of this of
this um so-called police interview the
first thing of course is this
that when when you
when you've established that somebody's
committed a crime or you suspect
somebody's committed a crime you have to
caution them you have to it's not an
option you have to do it
they didn't do that at all
this
demanding money with menaces this 60
pound shakedown that's because that's
exactly what it was it was a shakedown
um that was entirely wrong when they
when he said well what is section one
two seven they couldn't quote it
they were like they were like toddlers
at a pick and mix bar just hungrily
grabbing whatever they could remember a
little bit of section one two seven a
little bit of public order act a little
bit of absolute made-up nonsense they
didn't know what they were talking about
so that's also uh very very worrying at
one point um mr brady said well you know
i feel alarmed harrison distressed by
you being here
and they just ignored it they just
absolutely it just ignored that it's so
that didn't happen
so we said right what should we do i
said right i know i want to give them a
little bit of their own medicine so
we're going to turn up we'll have it
we'll have a bit of a plan but we'll
turn up and i'm we're going to have a
bad law project fair cop community
resolution order that i'm going to ask
them to sign so at an appropriate point
we will burst out and we will say we
accuse you of um of a breach of pace we
accuse you of harassing this chap we
accuse you of not doing your job however
he doesn't want to prosecute you and
providing you over hand over to us a
hundred quid and sign away your gill on
this dotted line just a year and we'll
send you on to a re-education course
where we will teach you about the
intersectionality between police powers
and the actual law and for that 100 quid
we'll throw in some sandwiches and they
wouldn't sign it for some unknown reason
so i said well if you're not going to
take that option option number two is
this and we handed them over a
pre-action letter written by our
barrister to hand to their chief
constable which listed uh the entirety
of their failures to date their reaction
was we're not postman take it yourself
um and then they try to dismiss us
i told them about ins about pace about
interviews and caution etc and they said
it didn't count because this wasn't a an
official interview i said no of course
it's not an official interview what
you're doing in effect you've got a
workaround system
where you don't think you need to
caution anybody
because you don't expect to make an
arrest and you don't expect to have to
justify that arrest to a custody
sergeant and you don't expect to have to
justify
the the the charge to the crown
prosecution service and there is no
expectation at all of this ever going in
front of a judge so of course you've
dispensed with the protocols around
investigation because you are conducting
a shakedown you've invented a quasi
system of legal summary justice and of
course you're nervous now because we've
just burst out the kitchen with our
cameras and we've filmed it all over
facebook and you don't know what to do
so of course that's that's what happened
harry just to put that in simple
language for people who are listening
who may not be familiar like we're not
really what you're essentially saying is
instead of following the procedures that
the police are supposed to follow when
they're making an arrest or when they're
investigating somebody
what they're doing instead is they're
using the fear that people rightly have
of being arrested by the police for a
crime in order to get people to pay a
fine and to sign up to some ridiculous
re-education course
instead of going down the legal route
right and they're using that fear to
coerce people to take that option yeah
and they're they're relying on the fact
that
even though the police are entirely
ignorant
of the law they at least they at least
look like they know what they're talking
about people are going to be worried
about the police yeah and most people
most people in this country recognize
that the police are the public and the
public of the police and that we police
by consent and if a police officer has
said i've done something wrong then
there's a fair chance that either i've
done something wrong or i've been very
very close to doing something wrong and
i better do as they say
um
that's what they've been relying on now
i don't know whether you noticed but a
few weeks ago it it was reported in the
press that seven out of ten police
officers have not in the mets have not
made an arrest this year now i don't
know this but i wonder whether at least
in part that is because they've been
they've been dealing justice by this
other means
that they've been dealing justice
outside of the judicial and criminal
justice system because
you know how much the police can say
that this was the first time but it
wasn't it's a little bit like when your
wife catches you watching porn never
happened then yeah you can pretend it's
the first time but everybody knows it
wasn't
and this is exactly i'm looking at you
there
this is this this is this is exactly not
even married mate
watches too much points
so
i think this is the same thing i think
this has been going on and on and on and
on and on we didn't get lucky on the
very first time this had occurred these
these officers were fluent in this
absolutely fluent in this and that that
massively worries now of course when we
confronted them
they had no answers they didn't
understand the law they didn't know what
they were doing and so they instantly
started uh mentioning words like arrest
and it was at that point that i i i got
in the way i stood i put myself between
the um the army veteran and the police
and said in order to arrest him you're
gonna have to come through me
um so
they called for backup
eventually there were eventually there
were seven police officers
there three i think at least three
vehicles including a you know a police
van
i tried to reason with them i tried to
tell them all the things that they'd
done wrong i tried to tell them about
pace and about protocol and how after
all this was simply a this was a meme on
facebook
and the person who'd the person who'd
sort of not invented it but had promoted
it originally he was stood right there
lawrence fox was stood right there
but they said we're not interested in
him because we're arresting you mr brady
because it's a result of your post that
somebody has caused anxiety and that's
why we're arrested so we're like anxiety
since when was section 127 of the
communications act or in fact
any act you can think of
triggered by somebody feeling anxiety
this is absolute palpable
nonsense so i just stood there and said
you're gonna have to to get to him
you're gonna have to go through me
um
i did advise mr brady to get back into
his garden and um shut the you know shut
the gate uh they advised me that i was
obstructing an arrest
i told them where to stick it
in no uncertain terms
and eventually there was a big enough
guy turned up um who who said right okay
you're gonna make an arrest now then
they did so
i got um i got
put in handcuffs
funnily enough i had to remind them to
give me a caution i said so i'm gonna
arrest him he said yes well are you
gonna give me a caution then how are you
anybody gonna caution me and then
eventually this you know remember what
the words of the caution were and uh
actually issued it and i i was i was
taken off and then with me out the way
they they then arrested mr brady but he
was quite
it was quite sad because there was
another guy there um one of um
mr brady's
uh army colleagues former army
colleagues they've served together
i think across all three um theaters of
war that they've been in
i'm just saying can you not see how
wrong this is you cannot see how wrong
this is we we we we were in ireland
defending the police we put ourselves as
bodyguards between the police and the
ira and now you're here
arresting this veteran my friend
over a meme
re can you not see
how wrong you are is there nothing in
you that tells you how wrong this is
and they were like dead-eyed sharks
for the first time in my life
i realized i think how
um
soldiers german soldiers in the second
world war
were able to march
peasants jews
dissidents
wrongans as far as they were concerned
into the woods and shoot them and simply
close their eyes and their minds
to
the reason and you know the course of
reason and you know is this why you
joined the army is this what would your
mother think is this really what you
want to do because we made all those
arguments to the police and they were it
was like looking at dead people um it
was like looking at people who were made
of made of flesh and bone but were
operating on some kind of automaton chip
where the algorithm had been clicked
and that was it there was no rationale
no reason no argument no appeal to basic
humanity no appeal to history no appeal
to context no appeal to anything that
was going to stop them on their mission
to make an arrest over a meme it's
it's a new form
it's a new form of tragic i remember
when i was last on your show you um you
you closed the show and asked what's the
question that you asked is there
anything that's um what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be yeah and i i said how
absolutely [ __ ] the rainbow is the
rainbow that rainbow symbol um which
used to be a great symbol of hope for
lesbians gays and by people
i now equate it to um
i think it's so corrupted that i now
equate it to a um swastika
well that shouldn't upset you
to me to me it has the same visceral the
same visceral reaction because it speaks
of an ideology which i think is
insidious
dangerous and which is
just sweeping through
organizations like reasons breathe
france's
is the internet going into [ __ ]
meltdown
and i remember you saying oh my goodness
you'll crash the internet saying that
but i think
i think i've been proven right except i
don't think it's the rainbow flag i
think i was wrong about that i think the
actual rainbow flag is is quite benign
actually i don't really have a massive
problem with the rainbow flag what i
have a huge problem with is the
intersectional flag
which is you know during during pride
month in london
it was like they were preparing for a
nuremberg rally it was everywhere i was
staying in in
wembley park
um this week and every doorway has got
the intersectional flag on it up and
down the street there's the flags
everywhere
and i i think they do it in order to
make you believe that resistance is
futile
that this is so established and embedded
within our culture now it's so accepted
within our culture that any form of
resistance is is futile and it's wrong
and he puts you on the wrong side of
history
that that's the problem
and so
i i think i was absolutely right i got
the flag wrong but i think the
intersectional flag is as close to
uh the swastika as um as as i as i can
think now
the problem is people always always
invoke is it godwin's law and say the
second that you you you mentioned hitler
you've lost the argument well i think
that's a cheap and very lazy argument in
actual fact because the problem is most
people when they think of
nazism they think of that period 1943 to
1945 which is which was the height of
the death camps
and the extermination of the jews when i
talk about nazism what i'm talking about
is the 1920s and the early 1930s because
that's where the rot starts that's where
the rot starts and by the time you get
to auschwitz and invading poland and all
that kind of stuff
it's over it's game over so what you
need to do the white you know those of
us who are wise
need to look at the warning signs early
on and cry out early on and saying this
is simply wrong this is this is fascism
wrapped up in a rainbow this is this is
a form of social architecture which will
stand no criticism no mockery whatsoever
and if you do so you do it at your peril
you will end up on a list of hate
you run the risk of being arrested you
run the risk of being thrown in jail you
run the risk of all sort of state
intervention now that as far as i'm
concerned is
far too close to fascism it's far too
close to stalinism and maoism than i
want to be and i think um
i think it was it was after i've been on
your show last time the court of the the
high court hadn't given their ruling
when i was on your show
but if you remember when they did
eventually give their ruling in the case
of homicide police's action toward me in
a very very long and significant
judgment
the high court uh judge mr justice
knowles
rounded off by saying we have never had
a stasi a checker or a gestapo we do not
live in an orwellian society now at the
time people said that he was being he
was using hyperbole i don't think he was
i think he saw very clearly the
direction of travel and there is nothing
that has happened since
that has even begun to be to dissuade me
that that opinion was absolutely correct
i think it's
i think it's terrifying
harry how have we come to this point how
have we come to this point where people
are literally being arrested for memes
how have we descended to this
i don't know i i think part of it
stems from
i think it was the 2002
police act changed the oath of
attestation that every police
every bobby swears to the queen okay
now prior to 2002 you'd swear to the
queen to keep her peace keep the queen's
peace and to uphold the law without fear
or favor
in 2002 there was a subtle change so
it's upholding the queen's peace or
polling the law
and human rights
it's like hold on a minute that sounds
good but why do we need to have this
addition of
and human rights in the oath what's
wrong with simply the law because if
there's a human right that if the human
right is within the law then we don't
need to say and human rights and if the
human rights are outside of the law then
by definition it's contested and it's
therefore political so we've given the
police
a virtual obligation
to listen to those
human rights organizations who have the
most influence who are shouting the
loudest and for them then to adopt the
policy as though it were law and uphold
it as though it were law of those human
rights organizations one of those
organizations is of course uh stonewall
and stonewall have been saying for a
long time that um
trans rights are human rights that trans
uh that trans women are women that
gender identity trumps sex but worse
than that
that anybody that that disagrees that
anybody that doesn't accept these
statements of facts are de facto haters
um and not only that saying it
is they call it anti-locution and to
express
to express dissent or disagreement
disapproval or disbelief to these
mantras
is to be on step one on a five-step
journey
to genocide
that's what it said it's called it it's
called the allport scale where hurty
words
lead to hurting violence which leads to
murder
which leads to genocide and they are 100
percent committed to this to this
trajectory
do you think part of the problem was
obviously the met made such a horrendous
mess of the stephen lawrence murder and
then it was then found to be
institutionally racist by i think was a
mcpherson report
do you think this is and
what they've done is they're trying to
over correct yes that's that's exactly
it so what we have we have a problem of
we have a problem of this this human
rights element where they're committed
to that and then we have a problem of
institutional
guilt
where you know they were they were
perhaps behind the curve
in the past and now rather than being on
point they're trying all the time to get
ahead of the curve
so as far as they're concerned it
doesn't matter if they're on the wrong
side of the law providing in their minds
they're on the right side of history
that's the problem that we have wow that
eventually the law will catch up with
them wow yeah that's that is that is the
problem they they police
according to a law that they hope to be
rather than policing according to the
law as it is that is very very worrying
harry but you're i mean that's a
fascinating insight actually i hadn't
thought about it like that but you're a
former police officer right
how is it that the people who are doing
this and their police chief constables
and the people who are in charge
how is it that they're not seeing what
they're doing how how do they not see
that arresting people for sharing memes
may be crossing a line
because in their minds they're
preventing genocide that's it when we
asked
why have you intervened in in harry
miller posting a limerick
they said because of stephen lawrence
that's that was their one and only
answer
and um i said well steven lawrence
wasn't murdered because of memes
no he wasn't but in their in in
according to the alport scale the scale
of escalating violence
you can trace
you can trace violence murder and
genocide
to
controversial speech and this is how you
get to you know if someone says the
wrong thing they should be prosecuted
because so yeah so you're stopping a
genocide yeah so you have you have
pre-crime which is what i committed
otherwise known as non-crime a non-crime
hate incident based on the perception of
somebody else or a police officer that's
handy isn't it
and without intervention
this will escalate to
the death of stephen lawrence as i
pointed out to the police i think you're
a little bit late stephen lawrence is
already dead but um never mind they've
taken this notion of escalation
and they do not apply common sense now
one of you you mentioned common sense
following the uh the high court victory
against homicide police i had i had
coffee with the chief constable of
homicide
and you know he was he was very
apologetic in a very dead-eyed way um he
didn't behave like a man
who'd understood the full import of
being compared to the stars of the
checker and the gestapo i mean one of
them fair enough but all three that's
terrible it's a little bit like a health
service being compared to beverly allett
joseph mengele and harold shipman isn't
it
um it didn't seem to have any emotional
impact on him whatsoever
and i i said to him i said ugly i kind
of get why a young officer who's just
been on a course
overreacts to something but when the
world's press
turned on homicide why did somebody up
the chain of command not apply some
common sense
he looked me straight in the eye and
said harry you should understand that
common sense is not an appropriate tool
for a police officer
because it leads to unpredictable
outcomes what we need is more guidance
that for me is as terrifying a statement
as i've ever heard
of course we want police officers to
have common sense but even worse our
entire
our entire relationship with the police
and with the law is based on common
sense we we operate as free people who
are free to think to speak and to do
right up until the specific point
clearly defined at law where the law
says this far and no further now that is
based on a benign common sense there's
an assumption that i'm not just going to
come up and gratuitously punch you in
the face
okay it assumes that we are by nature
good people that we are by nature
sociable people that we have by nature a
utilitarian
understanding of life
the in europe of course they operate on
a different system they operate on a
system of permissions where the state
allows you to think to speak and to do
so i think one of the things that we've
done we've we've imported
a european uh mentality when it comes to
policing and that's why common sense is
nothing and guidance is everything right
that's that's i think is this is the
the nub of the problem and harry there's
also the flip side to this which is if
the police are failing in their basic
duties
to investigate
prosecute and imprison criminals they're
just not doing it i'll give you an
example so my parents house got burgled
my parents are very elderly my mom's
disabled they're both in their late 70s
my father's a full-time carer for my
mother
they were out
doing a bit of shopping they came back
dad came back disrupted these burglars
they literally ran past him thank the
lord they did because if they'd knocked
him over he could have literally been
killed yeah and they ran out and they
ran out and they took uh my mother's my
mom's jewelry and some of her mum's
jewelry which is the only thing she has
to remember her by and they stole it
thousands of pounds worth
my dad called the police they came
around did nothing if not a cursory
glance
went right we'll we'll be looking into
this but basically there's not a lot we
can do
and then by the time they drove away
five minutes later my dad received an
email in his inbox saying the case was
closed and here's your crime reference
number for insurance purposes there was
an article the other day that shows that
that's tragic by the way yeah but but
i think prosecutions or convictions one
of the two for crimes of that nature in
single digits in this country so you've
got the police completely failing as
francis says in their duty to the
citizens in terms of dealing with actual
crime yet they're able to send three
vehicles and seven officers to arrest a
guy for a meme yeah
does that make does that make any sense
to anyone
no well it yes it does make sense if you
understand that our police
are engaged in the promotion of an
ideology
so in in it's quite interesting you say
i think you say your mum was disabled
yeah she's now yeah so so disabilities
one of the five is one of the five
monitor strands
but it's not given anything like the
same amount of attention
as
as as
um gender and gender identity okay now
you would have you you would have got
further with that complaint had you said
that i believe that i've been targeted
because i am disabled
that would have made a that would have
made a significant difference
if you'd said i believe that i've been
targeted because i'm lgbt because of my
dental identity you would have everybody
including the chief constable there
they're investigating it because it
would because
the theft would be an affront to their
number one ideology that they are
promoting that's that's the problem
they're not that interested when i talk
about the police i'm not talking about
general police officers most police
officers are good good people who want
to do
do the job but the system is geared up
so that there is a prioritizing of
ideological crimes over any other crime
and this is very much
very much like as it was uh behind the
iron curtain well it's true and one of
the things i i don't think people in
this country watching this and listening
to this realize
how weird this is
like when we as i said we were in
america for three weeks talking to
people and this issue came up and we
were there while this incident happened
and we were telling people people in
america can't believe that this is
possible
no they can't imagine that in a country
like britain which is about as close to
the united states as you're going to get
in terms of the countries around the
world
people are being arrested
for what they say on social media yeah
i i it's i i don't i don't know how to
explain to people how wrong this is of
course it's wrong you know and and i
think i hear what you're saying about
the way police are but also to me it
puts into question this
this whole uh law
which says that you can't be grossly
offensive
well
now this this is why we set up the bad
law projects and called it the bad law
project because
fundamentally we think most laws are
okay
are are good but when you apply a law
you have to bear in mind what
what did parliament
what problem was parliament trying to
solve at the time the law was enacted so
what they've done instead they've taken
they've taken laws that were they were
designed to solve the problem in 1990 or
1997 or what have you and they're now
trying to apply it to this highly
digital age
so rather than going to trouble of
enacting a new more specific law
they've just
given the old laws a bit of a a bit of a
rebranding
um and tried to apply that do you think
that particular law should be repealed i
guess no i don't i think you don't no no
not necessarily no it's not necessarily
why should it be illegal to be offensive
it's not
it's illegal to be grossly okay why
should it be legal to be grossly
offensive
okay again it's target being grossly
targeted gross offense
so if i were to send you know to your
mom having been burgled a message saying
you know i'm glad i'm glad you were mer
burgled you you disabled
cow or blah blah and focusing on that
you know it's that's not just offensive
that's grossly offensive and it's
designed with with malice in mind
and menaces in mind there is the hope
that the effect i'm going to have on
your mom is to make her extremely
uncomfortable i'm not against
laws like that providing they are
applied in that way what we have here is
a unknown victim
just as somebody as somebody who has
said that opinion causes me anxiety now
there is a world of difference between
that and the situation i've just
described to you so providing providing
the law
is used in the manner it was designed
for
and it's not over extended into other
things i don't think there's a massive
problem necessarily with one two seven
there may be i need to look at the data
on it i need to see how it's been used
but i'm not one for saying just because
the law has been badly applied it
necessarily makes it a bad law one of
the problems that we have i always take
the dangerous dogs act
as an example because that is a prime
example of of rushed terrible law if
you're going to have a dangerous dog
site you've got to define what a
dangerous dog is you've got to define
what is a an american pitbull terrier or
what have you because otherwise you can
get somebody saying you know you get bit
by a chihuahua and somebody says i i
interviewed that as an american bull
terrier the next thing you know um
little ponzi dog's been been put down
that's a result of bad law okay
very very bad law
what we have here is potentially bad law
but actually probably not too bad law
being applied by
ideologically driven officers who
understand ideology but do not
understand the law
that's the problem and that's why when
we confronted them they were not able to
quote it they were not able to quote
they had a go at quoting it but they got
it miserably wrong now when i was police
officer and this is a long long time ago
a long time ago
um
we learnt the law by rote we understood
our points to prove if you're going to
if you're going to sort of um convict
somebody or charge somebody you have to
understand the points to prove prove and
tick off everyone that is reliant on
knowing the law
and they don't
they simply don't because the law is
secondary to policing ideology and but
that's a that's a fault of the
institution because these people are not
getting trained properly correct but
again that's a product that's a product
of design the college of policing which
as far as i'm concerned is the the
fountainhead of all of this nonsense
um they they they said it was
last year the year before do they now
only want to recruit graduates as police
officers
really so you don't want you don't want
x army guys you don't want people with
loads of years as experiences plumbers
electricians etc you only want graduate
security people yeah yeah why is that
now i've taught in university i taught
at university for many years
um and one thing that i know about
university students is you are teaching
them how not to think you are teaching
university students how to how to
achieve a set of predetermined learning
outcomes by using a particular form of
words and managing to cobble it together
within an essay or or or an exam
enhancer they want people who are
trainee automatons
that's what they want they don't have
common sense that don't have common
sense that have no experience of common
sense and they and the police are
actively against common sense because as
chief constable lee freeman said
it's not an appropriate tool for a
police officer we know that we know what
they think because they stand against
common law
they're not interested in common law
they're not interested in liberty they
are interested in in enforcing us into a
form of behavior and a form of words and
a form of expression and cheering the
nhs you know clapping everybody that
walks past with a pride flag
all that kind of stuff there's just this
this mass encouragement by the police
to get us to obey
and of course it's not it wasn't helped
either by by government during uh
lockdown
when
boris johnson stood there
you know with an expert on the left him
in a so-called expert on the rights and
he would make pronouncements from number
10 as though number 10 with the source
of authority when it's actually
our democratic parliament which is the
source of our authority so that's that's
number one error
but he would make these pronouncements
about lockdowns and this that and the
other not backed up by law guidance but
the police were enforcing guidance and
the public were led
to a position where they didn't
understand the difference between law
and guidance now then
let's just think about the death of
sarah everard for a second
on the normal circumstances would a
bright smart
feisty young woman
believe
if a police officer pulled up in a car
that she had committed an offense by
simply going for a walk
no
no chance no chance but during the covid
lockdown period a police officer was
able to pull up
say you're breaking the law
and she believed him
she got into the car
and we know what happened now that is
not at all to excuse um what that evil
evil officer did
but this is a consequence of the public
being duped
and confused about what is law and what
is guidance under normal circumstances
she would have run a mile
if a police officer had said you've
committed a crime by walking going for a
walk she'd have been off like a shot
but this confusion has led to all sorts
of
atrocities quite frankly being visited
on us
as a people by an authority which wants
us to be confused and wants us not to
understand the difference between law
and guidance
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com
forward slash triggered that's
easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter access of easy which
tells you everything you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
harry do you think part of it as well as
laziness on the part of the police
because
it's like take what happened to my
parents you know you're going to have to
get a team in they're going to have to
dust for fingerprints they're going to
have to take witness statements they're
going to have to look at other burglars
in the area they're going to need to
match it up or did they they do this at
a certain time they're going to have to
establish a pattern that's going to take
a lot of effort and man hours was this
your photocopy or whatever you do a
screen grab of a meme on facebook job
done yeah yeah
it's about yeah it's absolutely about
protesters i don't think the police are
lazy as such i don't think the average
police officer is lazy i think they've
been led a pile of [ __ ] about what's
important yes i think that's that's it
and again this comes we always i always
like to punch i always like to punch up
always um the bigger the bigger the the
authority the better i have no interest
at all in causing trouble for
rank-and-file police officers
um
they've been absolutely misled these
officers that approached mr brady on the
first occasion they said they were there
they were there on the instruction of a
sergeant the sergeants had the sergeant
had looked at the evidence and sent them
when they came back again you know
somebody somewhere probably an inspector
maybe achieved inspector would have been
aware of what was going on and they they
sanctioned it they absolutely sanctioned
it when
when when they realized they were live
on facebook
when they realized that they must have
been being broadcast to millions of
people
they just doubled down they'd no common
sense there wasn't there was no instinct
within them that said hold on a minute
we weren't expecting lawrence fox and
harry miller to come bursting out the
kitchen with a film group
really this is the meme tell you what
we'll do we'll we'll just say
we weren't ready for this we're going to
go back to the station and seek advice
from a more senior officer and then we
wouldn't be here now because it would
have been a tiny little story not a
massive massive story i am glad you got
common sense i know but i'm glad we're
here harry because i come back to the
law point i'm not sure i agree with you
man because if we have a police force
that is creating this
ambiguity about what people as ordinary
citizens are actually required to do or
what they're advised to do or the
guidance or whatever
i don't want them to have laws on the
books that they can misinterpret in this
way and with all possible respect to
france's disabled mum i'd rather you
were able to send her a hateful message
than people are getting arrested for
memes you know and as far as i can tell
as long as the police have the power to
misinterpret these laws in this way and
this is this is what i said at the time
not everybody is going to have harry
miller and lawrence fox turn up with the
film crew and get this film then what
would have happened to this guy if you
weren't there he would have been
arrested and probably prosecuted and by
the way the media would have called him
a hate criminal yeah
that's i i i i agree so if we're in that
position i'd rather that law wasn't on
the books frankly this may be
overreacting in the moment but i'm just
saying i i'm not comfortable in a
society in which the police have this
much power are you
no but again it gets back to what what
problem was there in society that this
law
was was designed to
you know to to to answer well you said
it yourself it's designed to answer the
problem of escalating levels of violence
towards genocide right no the section
two seven wasn't oh yeah no that that
was that was designed so for instance
let's just say we have somebody who's
sending dick pics through the post yeah
yeah a week in week out week in week i
think we can all agree that that is
grossly offensive yes all right there's
no justification it's not saying trans
women or
are men it's not that it's in a
different league entirely so you said
you send a bunch of emails like that
then i think section 127 um is an
entirely appropriate law
um to to enact in order to
stop me sending dick pics
to you i think that's that's fine
because that's the kind of problem that
the law was seeking to solve it was not
seeking to address the problem of
somebody expressing an opinion that
somebody else found grossly offensive
okay so how do we get there how do we
get them to understand that difference
then
training but i think i think this this
begins with having a renewed respect for
the law what we have to do is get rid
of this and human rights aspect of the
police oath
okay because whilst that remains the
police will continue to be seduced by
the loudest
voices who are pushing forth an ideology
it's quite difficult to resist when you
have amnesty international for instance
saying trans women are women alongside
stonewall saying trans women are women
alongside mermaids same trans women
alongside various parts of government
saying it and you've got the flags and
all the rest of it so
the police the police are confused dixon
of doc green is now confused
um so we need to get rid of that that's
one solution and then we need to revisit
uh what the relationship is between the
police and and the public and where do
the police get their authority from okay
so the police get their authority to
restrict your freedom to act in a way
which in any other circumstance would be
unlawful
you know putting somebody in handcuffs
in any other circumstance against their
will is unlawful
taking money off them as a fine would be
unlawful putting them in prison
that power comes from the queen
and that's why every officer swear makes
an oath to the sovereign because the
sovereign is not the government the
sovereign it's not the judicial
system the sovereign is above it all so
the police need to understand
the notion of sovereignty
that the the taking away and the
limiting of our freedom can only be done
by
an officer of the sovereign that's why
laws are enacted with the permission of
the sovereign it's the crown prosecution
service in my case it was the queen on
behalf of miller versus the college of
policing sovereignty in this country
means a lot
so we need to get back to understanding
to understanding that what we have at
the moment particularly with non-crime
hate incidents and
the police acting on behalf of
perception
if you think about it what we have is a
removal of the power of the queen to
to to the mob
now that as far as i'm concerned is the
definition of anarchy so we we have a
choice we either continue down this
route
which is mob rule where law is defined
by third-party perception or we get back
to sovereign rule
where law is foreseeable and the
officers of her majesty the queen
and that's
the limitation of our freedom because
they understand the sacred nature of
that and they understand by a clearly
defined understanding of what they're
doing and they say i am arresting you
because you have breached and then they
quote the law and they know what the law
means and they understand that this is a
serious thing it's not based on mrs
miggins down the road saying what you
said made me feel anxious do you not
think that this section 127 is not
sufficiently
specific for the context in which we're
now living should it not say something
like okay let's say you know it's about
targeted grossly offensive material sent
directly to someone with the express
purpose of
causing
great distress as opposed to this vague
thing that can be misused and we've see
it's not the first time harry no it's
not the first time this continues to be
misused in this way it seems to me like
it may have been a well-written law at
the time that it was written
but i do think it's a badly written
written law for the moment and i'm
talking out of my ass because i'm not a
lawyer i'm just saying this is what it
sounds like to me what i think one of
the consequences which one of the
unforeseen consequences of winning
against homicide and winning against the
college of policing and placing a
question mark over these ridiculous
non-crime hate incidents which are
recorded um
absent of any form of common sense
entirely on third-party perception
is that the police i think are now using
section 127
in place of that
so that they they are escalating it
directly to
a crime because they're now nervous
about non-crime hate instance so i know
let's lower the bar of section 127
and let's start doing people for that we
have a police officer from
leicestershire called pc watson who all
for this last week has been bragging
about um all all my ruling did was make
matters worse and that the police will
now use section 127 um to criminalize
those of us who otherwise would have
been dealt with as a non-crime age
incident so we we know we know that this
is going on um i'm i'm helping a chap
who who wrote a letter to the fa
um i think last year and he said
that um it wasn't a particularly nice
letter
he said that in his opinion um taking
the knee was a a fascist nasty
racist thing to be doing that um gareth
woke gate as he
was picking his team with one eye on
dive with more of an iron diversity then
on talent
uh and he he ended the um the letter
with the single word vermin
not nice it's not the kind of letter
that i would write it's not the kind of
letter that i would want my mum to read
it's a nasty letter no two ways about it
probably a fan of jack grealish as well
yeah exactly exactly
yeah yeah exactly okay the police
prosecuting 100 seconds 127.
on the basis that gareth southgate
has put in a complaint that it's caused
him anxiety
so he is being prosecuted he served
papers this week this is what i'm saying
man it's like this law
if the if the law allows for this to
happen it's not well calibrated to the
situation i agree i agree but i think i
think i think the first point of call is
to recalibrate the police and get them
to understand
what is the appropriateness of the law
if that doesn't work and they're still
confused then we need to revisit the
you'll be here new year you'll be here
in a year agreeing with me okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's got
to be wrong hasn't it it's got to be
wrong i mean it's completely wrong
what i'm saying
the reason i'm so angry about it is i
don't think people understand how
[ __ ] ridiculous this is
i agree i don't think people get it and
if it what it takes is for us to get rid
of the stupid law and to have something
resembling a first amendment i
appreciate politically that's not the
easiest task but that's if that's what
it takes because see this is the problem
this is my issue with with your approach
harry is the police are always going to
want to enforce whatever ideology they
have right and they're going to use as
much power as they can get away with and
the only way to deal with it is to take
the power away from them
well you know what i never ever thought
that i would be one of those sort of
defund the police mob
no we need the police we do but not in
its current form no we do not need the
police in its current form so what needs
to happen is this we need to close down
the college of policing immediately
because it is a it is a hate factory
sponsored by uh by public money it burns
through 71 million pounds of public
money uh to tell us that uh all police
officers must be graduates and um have
to see hater everywhere honestly
honestly you know you know the religious
fanatics who do see jesus in a slice of
toast
well this is exactly the same thing the
college of policing and teaching
officers to see hate everywhere right
now then
mr brady our our war veteran um
the police said that they used the
phrase this was a three strikes and
you're out he clocked up two previous
non-crime hate incidents this was his
third one and so boom that was it now
the first the first hate incident was
you know the meme of hitler and his
bunker that's been going around since
about 2006 yeah oh yeah from downfall is
it that one yeah yeah yeah so that was
classed as a racist hate incident so
that was strike one okey-dokey
strike two
was uh it was a picture of tom daley
doing some knitting and he put
tom daley's tom daley's knitting a [ __ ]
warmer
now if you look at the picture
it cannot be anything but a [ __ ] warmer
it is a knitted ball sack and penis
that's what it is it cannot be
reasonably construed as anything else
tom daley's holding it like this with a
smile on his face he knows it looks like
a [ __ ] warmer that's why he put it there
but the police have decided that this
was homophobic hate and recorded it
against mr brady as a as a non-crime
hate incidence homophobia
that's that's the state that we are in
but harry isn't also the problem as well
that the police are merely reflecting
the culture as a whole no the
universities no
let's define culture they are they are
reflecting a a powerful minority yes yes
that's what that's what we dictate
culture yeah they're lead customers
yeah which the which then trickles down
in society
the rest of us we are we are we are the
pros that's what we are we are we are
those who have not signed up to uh the
pollock bureau who are not part of the
stalinist maoist elites um and you know
how it was in in in maui china
you know you could you could say
oh you know i've only got one chicken my
neighbor's got three he's a capitalist
and they come down and have him shot
we're in that sort of situation where
neighbor can grasp upon neighbor where
children are being encouraged to grasp
on their parents where children are
being encouraged to grasp on other
children
um in in where was it um
i think it was
warwickshire a few weeks ago i might be
wrong about that
um
a police force turned up at the door of
a 14 year old
autistic child
okay
said that he was guilty of a section
section 4 public order offense which
with a repeat would would end in two
years in jail
what he had done was in the playground
he looked at a girl who was a girl
but who dressed like a well no a girl
who was a girl who dressed like a girl
had long hair like a girl
etc but who said she was a boy
and he refused to believe her he said no
you're a girl
so the the school
told the police
the police visited the parents
told it read him literally the riot act
okay
i have on tape
the subsequent interview between the
boy's parents the the child and the
school
we have it all on tape
and they say to him where are you
getting radicalized
where how do we stop you getting
radicalized because if you continue if
you continue in this vein and do not
learn how wrong your behavior is
one you would be fired from a job and if
you would say that in a pub
you would probably be glassed
what
you heard me right you would probably be
glassed they said that to a 14 year old
autistic boy yes and his parents this
was the head of year 10 and the head
teacher who warned the boy that unless
they could break the cycle of radicalism
that he would be sacked and he would be
glassed in the face and this was
supported by the police who told him
came to his house and said any more he
could be looking at a two-year jail
sentence now you tell me you tell me
that that's not fascism well that is and
that's what i'm saying what i'm saying
i'm more optimistic on the trans thing
harry because we've seen some good wins
in the last few weeks on that and i
think
when people see the outcome of these
lawsuits against the tavistock
that's going to open put it very mildly
it's going to open a few people's minds
to what's been going on
but on this law stuff if if this is what
the police are routinely going around
and doing i'm afraid i'm not persuaded
that the right training course is going
to do that these people cannot be
allowed to have this much power
well
okay back in back in the day prior to
prior to that back in the night the
1980s 1990s okay the police had their
problems no notice yes but they didn't
they didn't spend their time doing this
nonsense exactly they spent their time
chasing down burglars preventing
burglars chasing car thieves and all the
rest of it now what's got wrong i don't
think the police have suddenly become
utterly stupid
but if they have
it's a product of design because what
the college of policing and police want
is automatons not
not regular people they want an elite
police force that represents which is
more like the stasi these are thought
these are first and foremost thought
police ideological policing regular
regular policing comes second which is
why they want graduates who have been
exposed to this ideology who understand
it
and who know how to do tick box policing
yeah same as they got their degree by
tick box essay writing etc without any
form of critical theory critic well
that's critical bone in their body
just automaton the algorithm says
therefore go and do this this this is
law by algorithm and it it is absolutely
terrifying so i don't know you know when
you when you're trying to find a single
cause it's very hard no it won't be a
thing it's very hard to find it but but
what i do know is the college of
policing is one thing it needs shutting
down the the oath of attestation needs
returning back to as it was and police
need to understand that they have no
part in politics whatsoever absolutely
none if it looks political it is
political and that's it you just back
away you do not put a pride flag on you
don't do it i'm even now against the
thin blue line badgers that police
officers wear i'm not even persuaded
that the police should be wearing
poppies um i
i never thought i would say that but if
that's the price that we have to pay to
get back to policing that is totally
politics-free then i think it's a price
worth paying myself see i'm with you on
that actually i believe that they
shouldn't we shouldn't politicize any
institution teaching the nhs policing
because once you politicize something
harry you're encouraging people to pick
a side and once you encourage people to
pick a side they're going to look at the
other side as the enemy
as allies and enemies and then that's
very dangerous because the police should
be apolitical it shouldn't matter if
it's a conservative breaking a law a
liberal or
whatever it may be
if someone breaks the law they break the
law that's it their politics their view
their ideology is irrelevant well it's
difficult when
when only one side of the argument is
licensed to carry pep pepper spray and a
taser and that's the situation that they
were in and the other thing that we need
we need a policing brexit that's what we
need we need to get out of the of the
continued influence of of europe because
the national lgbt national lgbt police
network
now that is a network of of officers
they all have each force has its own
network and they're part of a national
network and the national network sits on
a european network which has adopted the
entirety of the policy of rainbow europe
which includes the criminalizing of
hate speech around a private table which
includes the criminalizing of any form
of descent within schools okay so we
need to have a full police brexit
no more colluding with europe none the
second thing we need to do is have the
national lgbt network shut down
because at the moment i wrote to every
single chief constable and said who are
your members and they said we've no idea
but if we did didn't know we couldn't
tell you because of gdpr concerns but
what about an foi request that surely
that's your obligation legally isn't it
no they say we don't we no they we don't
hold the information and we're not going
to tell you because of gdpr
so we have we have the national lgbt
police network issuing memes
that say
we stand for stonewall
not with stand for stonewall and then
there was this absolutely amazing one
that said um they they they they were
celebrating the inclusion of trans women
in sport and of course there was a
little bit of pushback from from
feminists and gender critical people and
their response was to say we see you we
have reported you
this from a police account okay we see
you we have reported you i wrote to them
and said
who have you seen
what have you seen
who's seen it and who have you reported
it to
because that's open policing they
wouldn't tell us
they wouldn't tell us so it just exists
as a threat
against
against people okay we had we had one of
the chief inspectors of diversity and
inclusion from the college of policing
wishing all the homophobes a super
uncomfortable pride month
what's diverse about that what is if
you're a what if you're if you're a
traditional christian what if you're an
orthodox
jew what if you're a traditional muslim
and you you have some questions about
homosexuality
that you're not going to celebrate it
what is the college of policing
diversity an inclusion officer
telling you from a police account that
she wishes you a super uncomfortable
month
that's where we're at
that's where we're at and of course when
we resist it
we're then told that we're the haters
i think we have a lot of work to do man
yeah he's by the sound of it we don't we
do have a lot of work it is
it is mind-boggling to me that we're
having this conversation
i i really genuinely don't know what it
is absolutely it's ridiculous
it is ridiculous that we are in this
position
um harry so i have no doubt that you're
gonna be getting involved in more of
these cases uh congratulations on
winning the last one
uh the latest with this guy is he's had
an apology
he's not had an apology um all
all interest by the police in him has
been dropped um the the good pcc
of uh new hampshire came out immediately
i can't remember saying don is somebody
i can't remember my second name she came
out immediately and said this is
absolutely ridiculous and they dropped
it i of course um was released uh
pending further investigation so
you know i may still be charged i really
hope they do charge me because i will
have a field day
yeah that's why they won't charge i
don't think and this is the other thing
see
this is why they didn't arrest lawrence
yeah
they they're targeting ordinary people
because they know how this looks to the
general public and they know that if
they arrest lawrence or someone like
that who's got a big audience
it's going to be in the newspapers
they're going to get ridiculous
well exactly right but my question is
what happens when if you and lawrence
aren't there
this guy's life gets destroyed right i
agree and so we we we got to find a way
to deal with this we really really do
yeah no
we we we've got our we've got our work
cut out and the reason that we're so
you're so aggressive when when we find
these things you know we're absolutely
merciless i said i said you know do you
want apology i said no i want the chief
constable said in my fridge
i didn't mean it and that is hp yeah
metaphorically
not literally
because what i want to do is what
they've been doing which is create a
chilling effect yes i want every chief
constable in the country to know that
harry miller of the bad law project is
their worst nightmare because if i find
out what's going on then we will just
unleash hell absolute hell because we
don't care
we're not we haven't got reputations
that we're trying to um
you know protect we don't care we're
just like bazookas we'll just go in i
can just
[ __ ] you up man just absolutely [ __ ] you
up if you treat the british public with
that degree of contempt i'm going to
take it personally because you're not
only treating the public with contempt
you are disrespecting the queen you're
just disrespecting the source of your
power and so i'm going to resist you
with everything i've got so you can
expect more of lawrence fox and i
bursting from the kitchens with the film
crew and jumping out of hedges and you
know leaping out of trees on behalf of
the great british public you sound like
jeremy beadle
absolutely yeah
i don't care though i don't this is the
thing they don't understand i just don't
care yeah i'll take them all to court
i'll fight with them all
because this matters you know just
watching your
your reaction about all this
i know that we're on the right side of
history because you recognize how wrong
this you recognize how wrong this is and
of course you have a bit of background
um from
from eastern uh eastern europe so you're
sort of familiar with how
bad it can go yeah but harry you don't
have to be from eastern europe mate
you've got to read a [ __ ] book like
history is filled with this all of this
people shutting down the speech of
others in order to control what they say
and think yeah you don't have to be from
eastern europe you just have to have
half a brain yeah no i i i i agree with
you i agree with you so for me i take
the approach you know understand the law
and then go right up to the edge yeah
good well look you're doing good work
i'm sure we will see plenty of you in
the future uh best of luck to you with
it all uh we're gonna ask you a couple
of questions from our supporters uh the
only they will get to see on locals
they've already submitted a bunch um but
in the meantime as you know we've got
one final question for you which is
always what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
um
i i think the one thing we should be
talking about is the um
the the vacuum that there is um in
the home office
that the the pretty patel
she knows that all this is wrong she has
the power to do something about it
and she doesn't do it she allows
she subcontracted it at no pay
whatsoever to individuals like myself
individuals like bose barker
and a whole bunch of other activists to
do the job the government ought to be
doing
there you go pretty if you're watching
sort it out yeah sorry i love um anyway
uh harry thanks for coming back on the
show really great to see you and thank
you for watching and listening we will
see you on locals with a couple of bonus
questions that you've asked for harry
and also we will see you
next week or in a few days with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
[Music]
what's the best way to handle the
situation if we unfortunately find
ourselves in trouble with the police for
wrong thinking this way
[Music]
you